should global businesses have a code of
ethics should businesses have a code of
ethics really funny I thought they
always did or always should have we have
confused a prosperity agenda for the
money at you what we have been doing has
been a money agenda that's why it ran
into a wall that's why it didn't work a
money agenda there's no agenda at all
America is not everything is not even
most things but it is a great example of
something it's a great example to what
once the yielded since you're called
America's special sauce and that special
sauce is I believe the power of the idea
what I mean by that Ted Turner the
founders seen in he didn't wake up in
the morning and said I want to be rich
and powerful Steve Jobs the founder with
the de facto founder of Apple an
innovator for itunes and iphone and ipod
he didn't wake up in the morning said i
want to be rich and i want to be
powerful you know Klaus Schwab found in
the World Economic Forum didn't wake up
the morning and said I want to be rich
and I want to be powerful and you can go
on and on with these examples the
appointed is Bill Gates did not wake of
the morning said only rich i wanna be
powerful they said I have an idea I've
got this idea and I'm passionate about
this idea it's going to empower people
so the party would 24 hour news how are
people with a better way of living or
it's going to serve and help people help
themselves some significant way and it
caught on as a positive epidemic they
worked it because if they were
passionate about this idea and as a
result of it becoming successful it
became immensely wealthy and powerful
but you talk to these folks today
they're still passionate about the idea
Klaus Schwab 35 years after founding the
work on form is passionate about the
idea we've lost that the people who call
themselves entrepreneurs who call them
some CEOs who took takes a dollar bill
or the rand or the Powell's of whatever
currency the euro and they slice it up
into pieces and call that our inertia
that's not entrepreneurship it's not
creating valence you know I know so
should there be a business ethic of
course there should you don't have one
you don't have a business you you have a
slot machine but at some point that's
going to turn against you so we really
have two choices love in this fear in
what you don't love you fear and the
reason that the world is all screwed up
is that most leaders today lead by fear
and beers first cousin it's greed greed
best friend is laziness and
short-termism and all that feeds into
this I want to get paid money agenda
that has slammed us into a global
economic wall so we need a hard reset we
need to get back to the power of the IBM
we get back to a long note we need to
figure out how to do well and do good
capitalism for your free enterprise
actually relevant to the for capitalism
and free enterprise actually worked for
the whole we need to spread a movement
not your civil rights but civil rights
because if you don't have a bank account
and understanding of money and fredo
cries in financial literacy and 21st
century and the global economy you are
an economics late so you didn't have the
right to vote in 20th century the
century of democracy you are a slave and
if you don't have an understanding free
enterprise and capitalism and system in
the ability access it in the 21st
century you're still in that economic
slave so we need to empower people with
a uses crisis rables after storms this
is business ethics now of empowering
people so that you have creature your
clients like relationships and not as
transactions know if every banker and
lit money to their borrowers as if it
was their grandmother you probably would
be in this message we're in the day a
global call for a massive uptake of
financial literacy education and
empowerment around the world
will create stability will restore
consumer confidence will allow us to
have a business that is sustainable and
will help power he was to be their own
best advocate and protector for the
offender you heard it here youtube at
devils and it's cold here it's warm in
this building my baggage dedicate
passion was trying to make the world
other place grapples after skills